[Music]
you know this is smooth David deal yes
it is we know it's not smooth giant
steak boy we didn't take too long to get
right into that one didn't we so let me
what's up everybody how the homies doing
how you live and how you feeling it is
the lef koe man it is David deal back
again we were texting we text a lot yes
and then before the draft I was like bro
can't believe y'all are gonna take
Daniel Jones and you shot me back a text
you're like smoke and mirrors shut up
shut up and after it happened we got on
the phone and because I'll say I busted
your balls the first time you came in
here yeah it just as an Eagles fan at
the course of course but you do work
with the Giants you're doing their show
online right and I know a lot of people
want to hear I hear you've turned down
some interviews
yeah I've turned out a bunch today you
saved everything's for an Eagles fan how
about that I appreciate I think we're
wrapping up the giraffe everyone's
looking over their halls that are seeing
what they got but undoubtedly I think
Cleland Farrell shocked a lot of people
yes but I think when you looked at the
Raiders Hall and you saw him Josh Jacobs
and my guy Jonathan Abram you went made
sense leaders vocal and you don't want
to miss on number four so I get it in
positions of need now all made sect but
six Daniel Jones
I love the little smirk as you say that
everything every time six daniel Jones I
think it still has people in shock it
does I think that we all saw the video
from the giant stadium of booze people
are alleging the Manning family is
ushered this guy in I'm gonna open up
the floor what was your gut reaction
before they took it what did you think
they were gonna do and after it happened
well gut reaction when I'm
they're watching the draft unfold and I
see Devon white go five to the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers what you and I talked about
perfect fit Falls right into place
replaces Quan Alexander's axles need not
bowls needs him you have him in Levante
David you have jpp now you have a
semblance yet from the front to the
middle to the back end of a defense make
complete sense
Giants sitting at six with both Josh
Allen and edy Oliver it's right in the
perfect scenario it is like getting the
dude the golden ticket from the Willy
Wonka because that is the exact spot
that you need a player need that of all
the times fits the value that was the
whole thing that we heard throughout the
entire process is value Cleveland are
enormous down game changers to six and
we're not gonna sit here and talk about
this person need we're gonna talk about
value when you sit there and you can
tell me that Josh Allen at number six
doesn't have a better value than Daniel
Jones then we've got issues yeah because
what did the Giants need last season and
over the last two seasons yeah where
they lost over 16 games in the fourth
quarter they needed that pass rusher
they needed that guy on the edge that
could affect the quarterback and do it
time and time again especially when you
traded Olivier Vernon yeah to the
Cleveland Browns get Kevin's I learned
in return which is a great great
resource for you and your journey good
return it is a very good return if you
want to win now if you want my mang so
you get the Kevin site with I ants by
the way xxx and sacks last year you
don't have a Libya Vernon you have the
most elite speed pass rusher on the
board waiting for you you know you
usually break down pass rushers three
speed power combination speed I had Josh
Allen number one power
I did have Farrell number one
combination of both
Nick Bosa so at that point sitting at
six you have the combo guy gone
you have the power guy go on but you
have a homegrown Montclair New Jersey
prospect sitting right in your lap yeah
he grew out like really close to the
state less than ten miles away from the
stadium yeah and you want with Daniel
Jones
I understand that you felt that it was a
need I understand that if you believe
that's your guy
you're gonna go up and get them but I'm
not surprised by the Giants reaction I'm
not tonight stands right the fans
reaction
I'm not surprised about it what so was I
called you expecting you to defend
Daniel Jones and you didn't know because
at that point
I can't defend Daniel Jones because now
at that by the way it's not defending
Daniel Jones it's to Fanning Dave
gentlemen and that pitch Daniel Jones
didn't do nothing wrong and that's the
thing that Daniel Jones is gonna figure
out real clear yes if he can handle the
the heat or not because it's already
coming what's incredible is coming he
doesn't have to just perform
outperformed Joshua Allen no he doesn't
have to just outperformed Dwayne Haskins
or 1:15
he's got outperform drew Locke yep he
has to outperform Sam Darnell yep he
asked outperform Joshua on the
quarterback last year yep Lamar Jackson
all the quarterbacks they passed up on
last year all the quarterbacks they
didn't select this year he asked to
outperform say Quan Barclay yeah to show
that the value of picking Barkley in
last year's draft was worth it in
holding off and taking the quarterback
now and in regards to pressure a lot of
people talking today Monday after the
draft what quarterback is in the best
position a lot of people right away said
Daniel Jones well he has Eli Manning in
front of them he doesn't have to play
right oh well right right away right now
but when you look at being the number
sixth overall pick at the quarterback
position 90% of those guys play in their
first year you're getting drafted in the
top six I think seven and a half games
for Daniel Jones to start which to me
I'm going pound the under but you really
think you said this earlier in the green
room that if Eli has a rough patch
they're gonna feel the pressure to go to
date without a doubt because you're
crazy to me but because you're gonna
have to validate taking a quarterback
number six and 17 that's why if they
would have taken a pass rusher at number
six and they would have used the trade
package like they did to move from the
second to the first to take D Andre
Baker yeah and they would have moved up
to pick Daniel Jones the fan base would
not be reacting this way at least they
got because at least you got the pass
rusher you got the player in need at the
value that you said that it would be at
and not a reach and then moved up to get
your guy that you believe with the
franchise quarterback and the future of
this organization to transition out of
Eli Manning gentlemen has come out and
said that there were two deem two teams
that he knows we're gonna take Daniel
Jones before 17 I've talked to Scouts
and people inside the Denver Broncos
organization and it was a possibility
but that's still a 10 that's not at six
that's something that you can move from
17 when do you know that Denver Broncos
were excited about moving out how
quickly they did with Rexburg Steelers
so that's still an opportunity to for
you to move up to pick the player that
you want but still get the edge rusher
that we all know that this Giants
organization and this roster needs I
think the thing is too is there were a
few teams in this draft that if on the
Giants if we're gonna be very honest
because then taking Daniel Jones at six
the values way off yes however if that's
your guy I do understand not putting it
up to risk because when you looked at
the numbers there yeah
Denver was at 10 yeah Cincinnati was at
11 Miami was at 13
Washington was at 15 god those were the
teams that we were like maybe I was
correct but as we saw with Washington
all we we all knew they wanted to ask
yes like that was clear so then you
cross them off they're no longer a
threat yep the Bengals and the Dolphins
the Dolphins were in talks with Josh
Rosen Giants should have been in touch
to Josh angles were looking at Haskins
when they were initially Loretto things
but they didn't go quarterback I I
understand from a GM's perspective while
you go and get your guy the issue is no
one other than the Giants and like Gil
Brandt and David Cutler for the Manning
Emily thought he's the guy that's why
this has gotten so [ __ ] it's gotten so
[ __ ] I'm saying that with a little joy
he's because a smile on my face is
because they're there I'm not hearing or
seeing anyone coming out and going I do
believe he can be the guy like I I'm not
hearing a single person doing that Dave
listen when when you pick a quarterback
in the top ten and you know that he's
coming to your organization
number one do you know he's not coming
to a good football team there's a reason
why a top ten quarterback is coming and
in regards to New York Giants we're
talking about eight wins over the last
two seasons so you know you're not
coming in to well you have the full
supporting cast otherwise it would have
thrived under Eli because he had the
supporting cast so number one you're
throwing him into that and number two
regardless of whether he has say Kwan
Barclay behind him or not you're gonna
get thrown into games whereas a number
ten pick at the quarterback position you
better be able to take over football
games and win them by yourself and
that's our Daniel J and that's not right
now when you're looking at him as a
number ten pick everybody that talks
about it he has a year to progress he
has a year to learn and they can
continue to evolve around him and build
that team that's not something you do
with the numbers you believe the Manning
family has too much control over this
organization you know what I don't think
they do
I honestly I don't think they have
control in the organization but to sit
here and say that the relationship with
David Cutcliffe Peyton Manning and Eli
Manning had nothing to do with it would
be ridiculous yeah you're bringing in
somebody that you know was mentored the
right way
coached the right way knows how to
handle pressure in the state of New York
and New Jersey as a head coach but or as
a the starting quarterback of a team but
even saying that he wasn't a polished
prospect coming out like Eli people are
comparing him to Peyton Manning
yeah people said well Peyton Manning may
not have a stronger on the Ryan Leaf but
he checked off every other box on the
board that you were worried about you
see that nationally televised game the
Daniel Jones head last year where he
like kicked ass against that team no it
didn't
[ __ ] happen never [ __ ] happen I
mean humanik I'm watching like national
championship level games or SEC games
and even looking at Alabama you're
looking at Auburn you're looking at
big-name programs who did you know that
Daniel Jones ran for a hundred and
eighty yards against North Carolina
you know many North Carolina guys are in
this draft I don't [ __ ] know I don't
see yeah I didn't see any and that's and
that's what comes to the pressure of
picking a quarterback at number six and
putting that on him because that's never
gonna leave and when I say that eli has
control over the Giants
I don't always mean it's this maniacal
behind-the-scenes talk and [ __ ]
sometimes his mere presence is pressure
I have said this on the left coast show
and I said this before that the Giants
missed their opportunity with Ben McAdoo
they could have moved on from Eli when
Ben Ben Ben sat him and gone it was
Ben's decision and then the fan base
would have hated Ben but instead they
caved after one game of geno and brought
him back in and we never saw Davis Webb
and now it just seems like they're
trying to transition to a guy that'll
make it an easy transition instead of
the right guy it's like dating somebody
that lives in your apartment complex oh
you know what it's it's two floors yeah
yeah who the [ __ ] cares you got to hang
out with them all the time there's six
much you're gonna hate if it goes bad
it's you're still gonna see them in the
elevator but it's so convenient who
cares if it's convenient listen do you
want your transition to the next
quarterback to be seamless but at the
same time you want that transition to
have competition because that's gonna go
into Andrew Luck well you need to lose
Peyton for a year and go to and 14 to
get that exactly and that's the thing
that you realize with this is that you
have to have competition I don't think
Daniel Jones is gonna come and just
succeed his job and just give it to Eli
Manning but having said that the minute
that a game goes wrong the minute that
there is a bad interception thrown by
Eli man and he has that face what do you
think this fan base is gonna do what do
you think that they're gonna be calling
for they're not gonna be calling if he
was number 17 right they're calling for
number 6 because of the value that you
put them on
and the value saying that he is the
franchise quarterback if you say that
he's the franchise quarterback from day
one then then you should have moved on
from Eli Manning yeah that's the thing
if you say that you needed him to come
in and hurry million if you said that
you needed him to learn under a year and
you think that he can be the franchise
quarterback that's another thing but to
make the statement that right now he's
the franchise guy that's something that
none of us know I get the drop spies
receivers I get the offensive line
insufficiencies and not having the time
but if you're number one number
receivers drop a lotta balls and it's
not his arm is really good or he's
really accurate like if you're giving me
like qualifications about why he's not
bad as the reasons he's good I have an
issue my thing with getting win games
regardless of for the circumstances
around about they're the number six yeah
they'll get it done they'll get it done
gentlemen
his whole defense has been look at my
track record look at what I've done I
don't think he's actually ever brought
in a quarterback so that's like a funny
thing to say but I also think it's
interesting that I feel like they're
rebuilding but they're also going for
broke at the same time when you go out
in free agency and you spend the amount
of money they did on Golden Tate and
then you re up sterling Shepard and you
do trade and you get a guy like sylars
Eilers a guy that you put on a team when
you're trying to make a run he's like 30
yeah he's around that time it really is
this he hasn't been beat up you don't
see that he's missed a lot of games he
has that under his belt which is a girl
yeah if you're gonna rebuild you don't
you don't go out there and give se Kwan
500 carries you know what I mean like
you're gonna want to my fear is for a
Giants fan that the next few years are
the SE Quan show and by the time this
team is rebuilt and ready to go he's
punched out but that's my fear you know
what though it all depends on how you
look at it the reason why I say that is
because go look at last year look at the
2018 season the same thing after the
draft people were saying well
quarterbacks can last 10 years in
running back only last 7 how many games
it's a crime miss
zero sure how many to the other
quarterback Smith
each one of them missed a game due to
injury so when you add that into the
equation that doesn't always work out
the same way it depends on the type of
player I'm looking baby breakers you're
looking like I know that you're looking
long-term in the career yeah but we're
not talking about a six year rebuild
five year you don't have that amount of
time in the NFL when Gettleman says talk
to me in three years which has been his
big thing there's a way to the Kansas
City model now it's in the Green Bay mom
there's this thing that I feel like
gentleman is trying to do or he's trying
to call his own career trajectory shots
like hey I just drafted the quarterback
and I might sit him for two years you
can't judge me until he plays
[ __ ] [ __ ] because if he's
not good enough to get on the field
right now then it doesn't validate your
pick right like if if we're sitting
there at training camp and I'm watching
the video footage where they both drop
back and they both look to the left and
the team isn't like wow this guy's a lot
better than him
if Daniel Jones at 22 however old he is
isn't physically superior to 38 year old
Eli Manning like blatantly superior I'm
gonna rely on their distance we have an
issue yeah because he's not gonna get
more athletic yeah like there's 22 years
old you're a coiled up cannon and think
about that how many players are
projected from college and pros and
scouts and GM's say well he'll be better
in the pros than in college it doesn't
happen every way very very late to Shaun
Watson was one of those guys were like
his arm got stronger in the NFL and
you're like oh that's weird yeah I
didn't know that could happen exactly
but that's a very rare thing to happen
especially at the quarterback position
other positions are outliers but it's
very difficult to look at a quarterback
in college and say his production in the
pros is gonna be twice the amount that
he had in college man it's a difficult
position so I think the the Giants came
away from the Odell trade with Jabril
Peppers
Dexter Lawrence who I'm higher on than
allowing people I think I think people
wanted a pass rusher and they got a
defensive end and they're talking about
him like
you see tackle either talk about it like
he's like in 1995 oh he's a top 15
prospect I think he's more likely we're
giving him well he ran a faster 40 time
in 340 than Haskins yes think about that
and said 340 he ran a faster time than
who people thought was the number two
quarterback in this traffic law so they
got Jabril peppers Dexter Lawrence and
O'Shane ximena's ximena's yep not you
were looking at someone else there you
wanted I wanted I wanted West go out of
the tight end out of West Virginia yeah
he's a jack-of-all-trades he could be
your age back he could be a tight end
yeah put him on the line of scrimmage he
he can do it all I was you know
pleasantly surprised that he's in New
York yet now it really hurts oh sure
that but for him I mean I'm rooting for
me it's one of those players that you
watch on film and you're like this is a
football guy in all aspects doesn't care
whether he's catching the football
doesn't care what he's blocking yeah
they're getting the most out of him
every single play but I bring this up to
say I think Gettleman had his eye on the
wrong transition I think in gentlemen's
mind he believes he will be defined by
how he transitions out of Eli and what I
don't think he realizes he is currently
being examined with how he's
transitioning out of Odell Beckham jr.
yeah there's a lot of Manning jr.
there's a lot of Manning jerseys out
there but I would argue that under the
age of 25 there's a lot more Odell
Beckham jersey agreed and so right now
we don't have to wait Dexter Lawrence is
gonna play right away yeah Jabril
Peppers is gonna get out there right
away Oh Shane ximena's we'll see if he
gets out there right away I think he
will I think he'll be a good third down
sub package pass rusher but if Jabril is
getting beat deep and Dexter's not on
the field on third down then I don't
need to wait for Eli because you traded
Odell for those guys and could it work
out I think it could work out the end of
the day vitamin W winning it cures all
of this that's we're gonna solve all
this yeah winning and that is the only
thing that is gonna solve all of this is
winning I just wanted to look at what
the projected win total was in Vegas for
the Giants what do you believe it is as
I pull it up what would you feel
comfortable with Vegas I'd say seven
okay
Ceaser's has your over-under at five and
a half
all right that's low I think it's low i
think it's low i think it's low yes so
are you having a lot of Giants fans like
messaging you like what the [ __ ]
everywhere I go I mean I have a my me
and I'm at my daughter's school earlier
my daughter Addison's yeah shout out
Addison
one of the other teachers walking by
what did we do at six what is involved
in it but that's the great thing that
you love about being a former giant and
a Giants fan is that everybody's fully
invested in the organiz yeah but I don't
think they're excited
oh no and that's the thing like I said I
don't think they were excited with him
at number six I think they would have
been excited if they would have drafted
him at 17 or moved up to get him but the
value and everything that went behind it
at City that's what really shocked the
Giants fans especially with Josh Allen
who you talked about money-market
who brings the best to this team a pass
rusher right now in 2019 definitely
impacts this football team way more than
a quarterback if I would have told
Giants fans that they would have left at
6:00 with Haskins and 17 Montes sweat
they would have gone game-changing
defensive end that around a four for one
and a quarterback that's six foot to six
foot three and threw 50 touchdowns last
year I love it and I think that's the
other thing gentleman's not realizing
those two guys are now on Washington
yeah that draft Haskins sweat I can pull
up MOX where that's what Giants fans
were seeing in in January and February
and March flip-flop take the quarterback
first rents Vandor sue fence vent
quarter but the fact that Haskins and
sweat they're facing them twice a year
that's the other thing
if Daniel Jones doesn't play this year
and Haskins does play and has like a
seven we in a twin campaign with a lot
of hope that's even more pressure on of
course it is because it's gonna force
the issue to play him sooner than later
and in row that regards I will say this
I wasn't the biggest fan ask okay I was
not you remember I went back I watched
film I watched this entire season last
year
and they were just something about me
and about him that just didn't jump off
of the tape for me you know if I was to
put him in order I told you I'd have
Trulock number two hmm the fact that
he's had three different offensive
coordinators on his time at Missouri the
fact that he didn't have the talent
around him and the fact that he got
kicked his why should I'm about to swear
my daughter maybe [ __ ] kicked out of him
a game after game after game yeah and he
would have a linebacker coming down the
bow of the pocket on the Blitz and he
would sit there throw the ball and take
[ __ ]
yeah that's something that you want to
see out of a quarterback to get back and
bounce up granite Daniel Jones didn't
have the offensive line right but also
when you look at the intangibles the arm
compared to arm the college career
compared to college career I would much
rather risk stings on picking a drew
lock than the Daniel Jones
having said that time will tell and
let's face it that Shermer made Case
Keenum look like a freaking all-pro yeah
Minnesota he did so the short
intermediate game is something that you
can you think schirmer's all in on
Daniel Jones - I don't really think I
was a cattleman I don't think they would
have pulled the trigger if they don't
work that's the thing about Daniel Jones
it's so interesting is last year his
completion percentage was 60 the year
before was 56.7 and I know the drops we
can add those in that's fine but my
thing really is what I learned I stepped
away from the draft this year I have my
books I made all this so I can organize
I'm gonna go through kind of look at
what I thought teams needs were what
they actually fill compared to like what
I thought they were and then I'm really
gonna focus on preseason this year
because what I've realized about draft
analysis is there's typically two
different types of people okay there are
people that like to watch for traits and
then project them and a lot of times
they they go oh well the coaching is not
going to be that good at LSU it'll be
better in the NFL and we can I think
that's what's happening with somebody
like luck where we look at lock and go
wait until there's structure around him
wait until he has better weapons and all
that stuff and there's some people that
need to see it yeah and those people
love finished products that typically
have lower ceilings whereas the people
that like to project like to take a
little bit more risk because they go
look at the
athleticism Oh Montes well he didn't
know what the hell he was doing it mrs.
Riley and I'm somewhere I'm Finley
blinds like 25 years old everybody said
she has the best football IQ he's the
most prepared to walk in he could step
right in if a starter was to get hurt
manage the audience knows where to go to
the football but what was the problem
he didn't have the higher ceiling than
everybody else so therefore you restrict
yes your same thought process on
somebody if something happens right now
that's the guy you want yeah you want
the guy that can step in lead right away
right now because you can't project the
future at some point that potential may
be meat productivity and it may not but
what can't you Bank on you can't Bank on
the future you have to pick on right now
teams don't have two years three years
to rebuild yes GM's head coaches as
we've seen in Arizona with Steve Wilkes
last year you don't have that high man
no more why do you think that right away
with the second pick overall they picked
Nick bolsa in San Francisco you remember
it was brick by brick yeah well you
better have that wall built for 2019
because after this season people are
gonna be throwing things at that wall
sing well we had two three years to
rebuild your building all these
defensive linemen you're taking him in
the first round where's the production
just us what happens a little advice for
you don't don't talk about walls with
Nick Bosa because apparently he's really
into that [ __ ] he's really appreciate so
what you're saying though I actually
felt like a wit late was a weight was
lifted off of me for anyone that joined
me Matt Miller Connor Rodgers the guy
from sick to football and watched I did
the first three rounds of the draft and
the Melo came in and did four and five I
actually felt like a weight was lifted
because instead of arguing about DK
Metcalfe for three months and about
whether or not he was number one I got
to watch him go to the end of the second
round
to a Seattle situation where Doug
Baldwin's leaving and now I get to
analyze him like that instead of going
should the Raiders take him at four can
he be a number one he doesn't need to be
a number one no he doesn't need he's
gonna go to Seattle and they're gonna go
here's the deal lock it's gonna run the
middle of the field
yeah you either go a hundred miles per
hour
or you do a slant or you do a comeback
there are a teen and who throws a better
deep ball than Russell Wilson right now
maybe maybe one or two guys but it's
very rare Holmes yeah
so I actually felt like a weight was
lifted because instead of these dumb
[ __ ] draft arguments and I'm not
saying talking about the draft is dumb
just in general the picks and where they
go well that person and my thing is is
it Miller and Connor and I had to
explain this to them because I didn't
want them to get offended when you focus
on the draft all year round
you understand value you understand game
tape you really it you're at their
scouts yeah but for four radio hosts or
TV hosts when they get involved when
Colin Cowherd is arguing about whether
or not
Titus Howard is a project for the Texans
you've never watched film but knows how
no no and you know it's funny that you
said that because let's just break back
into it the opinions to break down a
film all that stuff that goes down the
fourth wall you and I were laughing at
that 12:00 pick with rashon carry to the
Green Bay Packers yeah there's a reason
why he should be crying cuz he just got
away with murder I shouldn't say that
that's okay she's got away with robbery
from going into the draft with yeah with
his ski mask on because who was the
steal out of that chase when efetch go
into the New England Patriots Jason Wynn
of itch had twice the amount of
production yeah I disagree on this but
this is the thing you watch film which
got popped off a film on you which guy
ran things down to the backside which
guy played every game and will
contribute on special teams which guy do
you know that regardless of whether he
has a Knick with him or not he's gonna
be out there on Sundays that's winning
Fitch
well he's a third-round guy doesn't he
fit the exact same well you mean active
linebacker that whose last name ends in
vich well when I saw that I was like I
believe that Belichick has circles like
the fact that you were not a patriot is
kind of crazy to me I miss I feel like
he circles those countries that end in
[ __ ] or Vick or whatever and he's like
these are my kind of guys let's think
about him put him in the same role as
Ning kovitch
I'm in the same role as who else who
else is a head coach right now for the
Tennessee Titans oh yeah very well yeah
that's all they're gonna have him do
because what do they do they draft a guy
based upon what he can do now and what
he does well not the potential of where
he can go yeah because some guys don't
reach it at the same and when you're
asking and when you're reaching
sometimes you know that that guy's not
yeah but you know that different coaches
require different stuff often I I think
peten in Green Bay right now is going I
got a bunch of guys already in the front
seven that are that are pretty good like
Mike did like I actually think the
Packers right now have a very freakin
sneaky D front seven so when you look at
their team they just went out and got
za'darius Smith adjust and some Preston
Smith yeah Kenny Clark and Mike Daniels
in the middle and they still have guys
like montre vyas Adams but then because
there's not a lot of pressure on a guy
like David and you know Savage yeah um
but I look at rashon Gary and I go if he
could be your guy off the bench on third
downs which is go kill the quarterback
yeah and he doesn't need that win of
itch of awareness I look at the Patriots
and go oh man they're gonna underpay win
events for the rest of his career and
he's gonna he's gonna man the flats and
their little SWAT down walls I think
different coaches look for different
like Belgic loves captains but see when
you go to that and when you look at what
New England philosophically does defense
yeah their goal with their defensive
line is not to get a set no not at all
their whole goal is to get him off of
the mark and to get pressure on them
yeah so that's why you see when you have
guys and they work stunts it's not about
one guy getting a sec it's just making
sure that they disrupt the timing and
the quarterback of where he can set up
that's the difference when you get into
different situations and systems I can
understand what you said three four Mike
Patton yeah put him on the outside rush
to run Bantam roll but when you take a
guy at 12 you better be able to get him
more into the rotation
yeah and play more than just having him
as a sub guy who were the other picks in
the first round that you really liked I
think that yeah here let me see off of
my mind
obviously Devin why he was my one of my
favorite guys really so as somebody that
watches film and you see him he
he's one of the guys that jumps off a
tape number one do you love when you're
watching a middle linebacker pre-snap
pointing dictating and telling everybody
else on the defense what to do right and
especially events like LSU especially a
defense like LSU from the top down he
knew exactly where to go his speed
showed up on film his intensity his
ability to lead step up when he didn't
make a play to make that next play and
the thing for him to be able to be a
three down linebacker run sideline to
sideline that's something that is a
weakness right now in the NFL with the
amount of sub packages and offenses
three wide 70% of the time you know you
have to have a safety or a linebacker in
there if you could have a linebacker
that can play the running cover it just
allows you much more flexibility that's
like you see right there pick number
eight Jay Hawkinson pick number 20 no a
fan the tight end
you need those linebackers for the tight
end to Chris Lynch from huge addition to
the okay yeah let's talk some oh L
because great know what this is your
[ __ ] special yeah and I should have
started there it's okay Falcons go-to
offensive lineman yep Chris Lindstrom
and a little bit later they trade up for
Mitch McGary Gary yeah is this the area
Caleb McGarry is this the future oil
line for the Falcons it's that's the
right side of their offensive line right
now and they've already got him in play
you like both them on type do caleb
McGarry
was one of the toughest nastiest guys to
watch in the offensive line
he beat guys using zero technique that's
something you don't see a lot
out-of-pocket Lana he's a six seven guy
long arms long reach and he will just
see people if he gets his hands on him
he just has to get his feet in his hands
coordinated yes and that's something in
that sarkeesian system with matt ryan
you know examines their cutter order
cards back to tear cutter by mistake you
know exactly where Matt Ryan's gonna be
in that system that helps them out a lot
bring in Lindstrom another Boston
College blue-collar sure throughout his
entire career brings that nastiness
didn't give up a single sack last year
it's just a lot about an interior grabs
me a lot of Chris knee say same type of
pedigree same lower guy but that's where
a lot of people put an onus on a pass
rusher on the edge yeah obviously their
job is to run the hoop but the whole
point of it is for the guards the center
to control the depth as
offensive tackle you can run by the
width but if there's no depth in the
pocket the quarterback has nowhere to go
and he's backing up right to where those
those defensive ends are under the hoop
Lynch room is that guy on the inside
that will not give up ground and that's
exactly what they need for a quarterback
like Matt Ryan
I'm surprised which is shocking to me
I'm surprised Diller dropped as much you
just got your replacement for Jason
Peters is he that good he is that good
he has smooth feet he transitions a lot
of people said well he's more of a
finesse guy you don't have to overpower
people in college if you get the job
done playing and play out that's why he
was a perfect pick for them what was it
at 22 for them yeah he is a great pick
for them yes sir when names I think he's
the most polished out of all the
offensive Sherman but if I was a GM but
I would never draft an offensive lineman
from Wisconsin or Alabama really yeah
the reason why they never hold up
durability problems is always something
when you go to those guys Alabama you're
getting the crap kicked out of you for
four straight years you're playing you
know full year-round football and the
same thing with a lot of the guys who go
to Wisconsin they're not typically 330
pounders all of a sudden they're having
knee and shoulder issues and they don't
have the type of careers in longevity
huh not so big in Wisconsin they grow
them up they build them up with the
weight and everything because they know
that that's power football first
instinct right away well Joe Thomas did
it Joe Thomas was a converted defensive
end after his sophomore year he was an
offensive lineman there from the get-go
there were a few other strats about the
last Alabama offensive lineman to play
over ten years I'm thinking cam Robinson
is on the Jaguars right now and he
already had injury problems last year I
know that Ryan Kelly had a lot of hopes
for him and Indianapolis he's been super
banged up ever since been banged up yeah
you got to go all the way to Chris
Samuels well I love tackle Washington
Redskins yeah that's how far back you
have to go to lose now my man to play 10
plus years hmm so where are the schools
that you would look for offensive
linemen from a big ten I would look
pencil not Wisconsin that's in one place
I don't know what it is about Wisconsin
but durability wise outside of Joe
Thomas they really don't last
I would look at interior offensive
lineman at that point as long as they're
not running a spread offense yeah then
I'm good with it
if I can watch an offensive lineman with
this hand in the dirt then I can
evaluate them what I'm looking at an
offensive lineman who half the time in
the third and fourth quarter techniques
out the window because they're just
running plays run plays just started in
front of me they're standing in front of
people they're looking towards the
sidelines there's a pace of rhythm and a
cadence to a football game that as an
offensive lineman you better be on the
attack and you better not be sitting all
right so to scout yourself right now who
is a player on an offensive line that
you thought was gonna be really good in
any year and you were wrong about mine
would be Danny Watkins the offensive
lineman the Eagles drafted the firemen
got it from Baylor you know from that
year it was like Jason Brown the Baylor
had all those offensive linemen that
didn't pan out you know and for me even
though he's had a good career from me
Jake Matthews I thought and granted I
know I thought he was gonna be a lock
and he's one of the guys that's still I
know that he's played much better as has
gone along but he's one of those guys
who saw coming out of Texas A&M they
this guy can be an all-pro yeah every
single year especially when you play in
that type of system in a dome and you
have your feet underneath you man you
can slow down to pass for so much yeah
and it just kind of hasn't happened no
they're a great career but not the
career I thought that he would have a
little bit of news and notes Kansas City
with Tyreke Hill has become a story that
we need to watch day-to-day yeah a local
station in Kansas City got audio were an
audio file of Tyreke saying some things
to the woman in question where he was
saying things like you better be afraid
of me pretty much admitting to like
having the kid all that stuff they they
have now reopened the investigation
Kansas City is suspending him but it
seems like we're in this holding pattern
right now to wait and see what's gonna
happen and then they go out there in the
second round and they trade up and take
me Cole Hartman the wide receiver from
Georgia who everyone says he's that
Tyreke guy yeah do you believe that that
draft pick was them admitting that they
might
move on from Tyreke or is that just they
needed a guy cuz I do think they needed
more weapons III think that they needed
more weapons but I think it was also to
send a message without a doubt believe
me I've been a fan of Tyreke Hill on the
field
yeah there's no way that I'll ever
support him or watch him again ever
again ever again you know me being uh
you know father to a twelve year old
little girl let alone to have a little
boy and to talk that way after you've
already gotten your second chance to get
into the NFL that's the one thing while
people deserve second chances
this isn't his second chance this was
his third chance what he already came in
with everything with the Kansas City
Chiefs with everything that happened
before
while this same girl was pregnant with
this same child so for this to happen
again I don't think you should ever play
in the NFL ago I'm unfortunately I don't
think that's gonna be the case yeah what
do you think somebody's gonna pick them
somebody that can run that fast score
touchdowns and turn around an
organization they're gonna unfortunately
turn a blind eye to it because at the
end of the day if somebody can sign
Charles Manson and he runs a 44 and
scores three touchdowns they're gonna do
it because it's a business and that's
about winning and it was someone that
was really shitty off the field yeah and
they didn't last long
really yeah of course because you knew
when it came time and when [ __ ] was on
the line on the football field that guy
wasn't accountable and it would show up
that's really my question is it's it's
not about your actions it's about like
your character and what's written you
look somebody before a game in the eye
you know the guys who are gonna sell out
who guys are you're a little not shaky
and you're a little not sure up yeah and
sure enough that talent that they had
dwindles itself out the door because
it's not easy to stay in the NFL it's
not easy you can get your foot in and
get the opportunity with that talent but
that talent isn't gonna keep you in
having the mindset having our knowledge
and the understanding and understanding
what it takes to be an NFL player is
much harder than feeling cool because
you are an NFL player and that's what a
lot of people fall into that trap do you
think there's any way to figure that out
before the draft yeah do you think so
look just people have been trying to do
that forever whoa watch the draft
evaluate yourself and where you just got
picked and look
the previous drafts of that organization
you think you're the only one that's
getting picked at that spot you think
you've been the only one to challenge
this person at their position oh no
there's been years that they've been
either trying to replace this but yeah
or upgrade this position there's been
competition regardless of whether it's a
first second round or a veteran you
aren't guaranteed [ __ ] no and that's the
misconception and that's the one thing
that's the reality check for a lot of
these guys because throughout this
entire process they've been getting
their ass kissed they've that haven't
GM's that's why I've been having agents
they've been having their family you're
the best you're the best you're the best
all of a sudden you're gonna get punched
right in the [ __ ] mouth yeah your
first practice and are you gonna have
that same support not gonna give it or
are you gonna have enough pride in
yourself to pick yourself up off the
turf because that's gonna happen people
don't realize that these guys when
they're when they're entering the draft
can go to agents and can say I'm gonna
sign with you if you cover all of my
expenses for training and that could be
about $50,000 a service you're gonna pay
for all of my flights you're not gonna
get a [ __ ] dollar like they don't pay
their agents it's a concierge survey get
marketing services or they get brands
like Nike and Adidas that because they
haven't made any place in the field yet
they're they're all potential they get
all these deals they get to do all this
media and all this stuff and then they
have a party and it's a celebration and
they get drafted and they're crying and
they're hugging and I've always thought
that that kind of an emotional release
is very scary yeah because I've always
had that in IPO or like when you go to
Nasdaq and someone's like and guess what
lyft is now publicly traded ding ding
ding ding ding yeah and they go up there
and they're celebrating the work has
just started yeah but they're all but
it's this celebration of this
accomplishment about how many guys
walked up there in the first round with
diamonds all over their watches and
their gold change so you were a fifth
round pick yeah who was your first round
pick uh William Joseph cornerback
defensive tackle from Miami he lasted
all but three years I had a great draft
class yeah who else is your Jeff a
second round was Oh see you man you're
sure he and I back to back would all
always go after each other at practice
he's one of the reasons why I turn in
the player that that's awesome cuz he
and I would push each other which fight
we'd punch each other and then we'd sit
in the cafeteria and dictate what the
person other did that's all I saw you
doing this I saw this and we made each
other better
yeah our third round with vishakha shank
oh sure forth very famous for his locker
room antics on television yeah eighty
member that a box it's a scary thing the
cameras got to worry about qivana angles
hair
alright so forth fourth was Rod Beiber's
oh sure I got a call yeah see yeah I got
a call on the fourth saying it's either
gonna be you or a cornerback didn't pick
1:40 rod Baber so I'm like [ __ ] I guess
I'm not gonna be a giant fifth around
comes around it's Ernie of course in gym
fossil hey you like that joke we're
pulling in her card right now I went in
the fifth round six round was Willie
ponder who didn't last seventh round my
roommate Kevin Walter who and yours
unless he did wane Lussier and David
Tyree undrafted or Graf dipped every
seventh round so when you're the fifth
round pick yeah so make know you ain't
got [ __ ] guaranteed view but my thing is
more sharing a locker is there any part
of you that looks at the first rounder
when they're doing all the press and
they're doing the press conferences
after practice or they're the ones that
maybe already have a nice car or maybe
some of their position group is kind of
gravity is there any part of you that
cait's your own teammate for a little
bit no I wouldn't say so because you're
happy and you realize that they worked
just as hard as you got you to give them
that opportunity so I never that they're
not working as hard as you well then
they're out of the league like William
Joseph glass yeah it happens that quick
so I'd never thought about it that way
my whole thing was I'm a South Side of
Chicago guy I am no silver spoon I
worked and earned everything that I got
and I realized by getting to the Giants
and being drafted in the fifth round it
was an opportunity [ __ ] wasn't given to
me [ __ ] wasn't caring to me and that was
very prevalent the first time I broke
into the starting lineup they run Bob
which is the slant right behind me yes
opening play the minute that they call
the play
he barber Kerry Collins Amani Toomer
Jeremy Shockey they all look right at me
Mia and see how I wanted to respond you
realize right now when you're looking at
those other faces in the huddle
I may be 21 but I need to get my job
done what did you say
I turned around and I [ __ ] moved to 3
technique and we ran slant that's one of
the other things is that Tiki Barber was
one of my biggest supporters from day
one I'll never forget I came off of the
practice field my second practice
training moving in with the
second-string offensive line and in the
first because at that time coming out of
Illinois same thing I played everything
but Center yeah that's the only thing I
didn't play I'll never forget coming off
at the second practice and Ron Danson
better not [ __ ] this up I said what you
guys better not [ __ ] this up I said what
Ron heals 21 just vouch for you that he
wants you as to starting right guard
don't mess this up
damn who are you working with there was
a rotation of guys but that was the
thing for me talk about a perfect
situation fifth round draft pick
versatility I played everything at
Illinois but Center when I was at
Illinois we ran the same exact pro style
offense it is real we watch cut up see
the Giants were blazing all I had to do
was transition and turn around the
terminology other than that I knew the
entire office when when I'm getting
ready for the draft and I see that an
offensive lineman has played all over
the line it's a great how much how much
value is that it's huge because figure
game day you're only suiting up seven to
eight may be offensive lines the thing
people don't realize one guy gets hurt
that guy goes in you only have two other
offensive linemen and if one office out
here I'm not we've seen more offensive
linemen get hurt I'll never forget in
2006 I got hit by your old defensive
back safety Michael Johnson of course I
get harity - I get hit no six and I get
a stinger I felt my ear touched my trap
my my neck is on fire at this point I
already played left guard and then our
right tackle got hurt and I was playing
right tackle so now we're down to six
old linemen and I just got a burner and
I'm like my arm goes numb I'm going to
the sidelines where did you get hit for
a burger - have I got hit right in the
side and I felt literally like right in
the front left I felt my ear touched
am i right children when you say a
burner doesn't mean it really there's a
cigarette get and put out right in your
neck it's a burner yeah so your nerves
pinched whiplash yeah it's it's a
pinched nerve and it's like literally
let burner it's like somebody's putting
a cigarette or cigar out right here so
when I hear Pam Oliver ago and
apparently David deal has a burner yeah
how many plays will that impact you it
did it cuz I look to the sidelines and
they're asking if I'm alright and my
offensive line coach at the time Pat
flirty is sitting there Tyrus guy
talking to Fred Robbins or defensive
tackle going through the snap count Wow
Fred Robbins would have had to go in and
play guard for how many plays did you
feel it though oh I felt that the rest
of the game and the rest of the season
was it constantly that so yeah anytime
that you get hit you feel it it gets
jammed up I'd get massage acupuncture so
is that most guys when I hear a guy get
a burden today usually you feeling it
the whole year oh yeah the only day that
you feel good especially as an offensive
lineman is a day before training camp
you've got something wrong with you all
season whether it's the hair yeah yeah
you got a shoulder you've got a knee and
ankle you play through it you have to
that's the one position on the line that
I loved and the one position on the
field that I love because you never see
us never see a snapping our helmet come
out yeah ever ever have you ever been on
a team with a guy that did no cuz he
wouldn't be in an online room no chance
you can you can't be soft and play
online so like it could be a soft
basketball player you can't be a soft
online so I have a feeling that Andre
Dillard for the Eagles because he played
an offense that was a lot of passing
yeah he's probably gonna get tested
early in terms of how physical are you
he will you know what I mean like would
you with the rest of the offensive line
test a new guy or would the defense test
the game well I mean to go back to that
I'll never forget after I broke into the
starting lineup my first week of the
regular season that was the first time I
ever went through a practice without
getting into a fight because I'll every
single practice myself and SOI Burt we'd
be fighting people and then all of a
sudden were in the first week of regular
season we're playing the Rams at home
and it's like the fifth six periods and
I look Keith Hamilton I'm like you got
no problems with me today
no rook you made the pass
they were all testing me to see if I
continued to fight back so everyday
somebody'd start something with me to
make sure this guy's a legit guy he's
gonna fight back and no matter who it is
and the minute that I passed the test
they were good so the Eagles jumped
houston yeah huge we're gonna take him
we're gonna take him which is why it's
great then they took Titus Howard and
then Houston came back a little bit
later and they took a right tackle that
had a little bit more promise a little
bit more seasoning but the guy they took
Titus Howard is super raw raw Andre
Dillard gets to learn under Jason Peters
yep which I'm assuming is invaluable
invaluable not to mention you drafted
the big Australian last year did Jordan
my alotta and that's your future right
tackle so but when I look at a guy like
Titus Howard yeah and he's a super
project and he's going to a team with no
super Hall of Fame caliber veteran in
terms of like what that means for an
offensive lineman it's a lot yeah can
you break that down well the thing is is
that it's going from one structured
program to the other you have veteran
leadership in front of you that you can
follow you can watch and learn from and
Peter's is not a guy that's gonna worry
about losing his job
no not absolutely not he's a great guy
in the locker room even when he was hurt
he was in the OL lying room trying to
help me out shouldn't help vitai out
through everything so you don't get
selfish guys like that in the offensive
line room everybody understands that
once your expiration date comes it comes
there's nothing that you can control
about it whether you take yourself off
of the shelf or because of injuries and
the way that you do linemen get that
more than other without a doubt because
that's the only position where all five
guys have to play in harmony otherwise
nothing's gonna happen that's the reason
why is because you have to be unselfish
to play online you have to understand
what you're doing on your left side how
it affects the right side at the office
so if you're [ __ ] over that guy
you're really [ __ ] over yourself yeah
because if you don't pick up a stunt or
do something on your side and you don't
communicate it to the other side who
knows if they're gonna pick it up or not
how are you doing in your play what's
affecting the other side and that's
something that what happens with
offensive line play that no other
position understands granite well you
consider and say well defensive line you
know they have to
stunts but those are select few oh my
and have to be on the same page for City
play so the tightest Howard goes to
Houston is he kind of having to learn
this all by himself well obviously Mike
devil and offensive line coach of the
Texans yeah it's a great offensive line
coach I know him very well but when you
have a project especially when you don't
have the time during the offseason to
groom guys right it's a difficult
position granted but while the CBA you
know this and that it is not easy and
comfortable moving the guy from point A
to point B up against his own will
you've got to learn and physically grunt
through that work through practice to
understand number one what it feels like
and two to build up the callus of being
an offensive lineman two hits with your
shoulders you have to get your shoulders
and everything in your shoulders built
up you have to get everything in your
legs knowing that you're not gonna feel
perfect and what its gonna be like to
take over a game and a third and fourth
quarter those are things that you have
to get done in practice that's why every
time we've talked about the NFL over the
last three years the biggest issue over
the first four weeks is how bad
offensive lines ba defense is on the
first few days o in the first few weeks
because nobody's playing in harmony
nobody's playing cognizant with each
other and they don't have their footwork
in their technique down to where
everybody's coming off and sink when
you're watching zone plays what did you
think about Kodi Ford falling and JaJuan
Taylor falling I wasn't surprised about
Kodi Ford because he's an inside-outside
guy is kind of a mauler and if you go
back and you look at Zeus jr. last year
the same the same make a big mauler guy
gets his hands on you it's over in a
foam box it's when you get his feet
caught yeah that's where those edge
rushes and can work those one-on-ones
that's where I feel like he dropped
because every other one of those tackles
you knew was a short tackle right with
Corey Ford it's well he could be a right
tackle but we project him more inside
gotcha
what about Greg little did you like him
Greg little same thing
tons of starts an old Massa by Caroline
drafted by Carolina who I think Carolina
and the NFC had probably one of the dref
best draft classes I look in the embassy
I look at Carolina and Chicago I think
did well and I look at the AFC I think
Baltimore and New England there's
actually in the AFC more killed it
Baltimore is interesting they got a lot
of teams speed getting the kid from know
David why reciever Boykins and then also
a Hollywood Brown how they get the the
kid from Louisiana State the defensive
end yes people think is a sleeper
perfect pick Ben powers the offensive
guard from Center right from Oklahoma
can fill in and play right there the
teams that really stood out to me I
really loved Buffalo's Draft because he
didn't force anything
nothing I've had Oliver the one coming
out of the coming nine and fall red knee
wrap it couldn't work out perfectly I
actually had them if Oliver wasn't there
I actually had them picking Andre
Dillard to secure both bookends to make
sure they protect Josh Yale and what I
love that was their big issue Astrid was
there a lot what I love about what the
Bills have done with Brandon being who I
think is a very underrated GM I love I
love Shaw mcdr they they truly know what
their identity is and I've been kind of
preaching them up and it's a lot of free
agents that nobody really gives a [ __ ]
about but I do is when you sign
tightness ecchi Mitch Morse lay jury and
Waddell quit in Spain and they add on
there Spencer long and John Feliciano
yeah and then you still get a Cody Ford
what I see is you're building up your
too deep yeah of your offensive line not
to mention one of those guys can be a
jumbo guy absolutely about what New
England at a time the sec eel Adrian
Waddell were both guys for Washington
New England respectively that when
anybody went down that guy filled in for
the rest any position exactly and I look
at Buffalo as a team that's going you
know what I don't know if Josh Allen's
gonna be the most accurate quarterback
in the world but I'm gonna protect we're
gonna pound the [ __ ] rock cuz he can
throw that deep ball every now and then
and our defense which was first to the
NFL in passing last year can get it done
iving the bills are a sneaky team I do
too but they're in the AFC so I can't
really get excited about them when Tom
Coughlin got fired from the New York
Giants or stepped down janna look at it
that was who I thought should have been
the head coach of new John's with Sean
McDermott obviously I've been on the
other end when he was the defensive
coordinator under Jimmie Johnson and
part of that Philadelphia sanitary code
I've sat down with him a ton of times
when it calling Carolina's games in
Carolina he gets it he's a tough mother
he is a tough dude I think he wrestles
his players sometimes he doesn't take
[ __ ] and you love that on the other
draft
I loved personally was never Broncos
without a doubt because to go and get
not just drew Locke at 42 but to get in
front of him the tight end that he'll be
passing to for the rest of his career
you a fan and Dalton riser the offensive
lime that can play all over off dude
before you get him I thought was awesome
and you get a third-round pick for next
year by trading back and in the third
round you get draymond Jones defensive
lineman from Ohio State I just looked at
like need need need and it made a lot of
sense and I'm not usually someone that
celebrates John Elway after draft no
well obviously there's a little bit of
stability with Vic Fangio coming in yeah
and then not pressing the issue a lot of
people were thought well maybe they jump
to Drew Locke the fact that they sat and
we're calm traded out of ten with
Pittsburgh yeah got more picks to fill
needs immediately right now in it for me
AFC West is open outside of Kansas City
I think with Tyree kill I think a JD I'm
suspended it changes everything I see
that anymore is everything so now think
of no Tyree kill and no running back and
Hut right that's a big difference than
offense huge we're looking at 12 seasons
in they were the stabilizing forces of
absolutely and I don't think Oakland's
has signed a lot of people but I never
have faith in the teams that sign a lot
of free agents and there's just too much
gluing and and the Chargers are they're
there they're there they're still
haven't pushed past that point yeah I
think this might be the year the
Chargers clearly win the West I love
their pick of nests here at early in the
second round and Jerry Tillery in the
first yep they needed depth on the D
line and you get a safety that you can
pair with Derwin James and it's like and
they're both [ __ ] balls we love that
somebody down in the box somebody drop
out yes so much with their blitz back
and at the same time
you mentioned the Patriots yeah and the
[ __ ] Patriots go out there and they
get Nikhil Harry and I had looked at the
Patriots and gone wow they lose Josh
Gordon they lose Grunk
they lost their 250 50 guys yep because
that's where Brady is and that's what
shows you when they move grok out to the
outside it showed you how much in the
playoffs they missed that big body
receiver especially in a red zone
because the Patriots offense is
efficient yeah but it is also repetitive
and so when they play teams like the
Dolphins at home they're gonna [ __ ] him
tear him up with the slots and the pop
passes in the play actually because they
can't stop but when it gets to the elite
teams in the playoffs you need the 50/50
balls yeah and that's why when they
drafted Nikhil or put him in the slot
and get in the quick ball and let it got
make up a Miss they needed those
athletes on the outside think about last
you see how much people were laughing at
Cordell Patterson right they sign this
guy what's he gonna think about the
impact he had on special teams and on
offense running the football at times to
help them win a Super Bowl Josh Rosen
goes to Miami yeah which I think was the
big trade we were all waiting Steve
Smith you know this I love you buddy
you like that speech I do I [ __ ] hate
it I do age if you're not on Instagram
you can't tell people they're being
immature on Instagram that whole speech
started because he unfollowed the
[ __ ] Cardinals on Instagram Steve I
love you I love the [ __ ] hey Steve
I'd love to have you in the chair and
have a conversation with you but my
thing is that was clearly some stuff
that was built up from before because if
I'm Josh Rosen why would I want to
follow any social media the Arizona
Cardinals do you know that the Arizona
Cardinals change their social handle too
we drafted Kyler Murray so you're
telling me that no I had five guys
drafted at offensive tackle do you don't
think I realize competition yeah but you
weren't in the Twitter Instagram
what's a fifth-round guy what you're
gonna get sensitive now no but who say
that sensitive I'm saying that if you
know that a team is trying to trade you
yeah they know that you know that
they're trying to trade you and they're
gonna move on if you know if I know that
my fiancee is gonna break out with me
and she's hosting him on Instagram she's
posting on Instagram pictures with other
guys I'm not giving him drugs I am NOT
gonna win absolutely not do just follow
just waiting people are just waiting for
that to happen
no the real thing is is why are we why
are we going on NFL Network and going
breaking news
he's unfollowed someone on Instagram
I'm just saying I love what Steve said I
loved exactly what he said because it's
the truth
you really believe if Josh Rosen stayed
that he could have competed with Kyler
for the starting job that's your job but
do you believe that he would have had it
everybody in the world knew that Josh
Rose was gonna be on the Cardinals prove
him wrong the Seattle Seahawks paid
Flintshire drafted Russell will Shimura
third round and they had another
quarterback in Jackson yeah Russell
Wilson was not drafted first overall and
Matt Flynn was not drafted top ten the
year before how often does that pan out
does it always work no I just think that
I I think by him doing that he fed right
into the stereotype what would you agree
that he's handled everything perfectly
afterwards what he gave the little video
did a little speech his press
conferences in my hand I was excited
that I was happy that he went the Larry
Fitzgerald charity event on Saturday
absolutely yeah that's what he should do
but to feed into it it wasn't everything
he didn't need Mike my question is this
about Josh Rosen we keep listening to
these [ __ ] college coaches talk about
what these personalities are like but we
have met him but what okay well they met
him in person and what do you think
about him that's the thing I don't know
I don't know if he was telling me what
he truly believed or not because I think
you just have in the back of your head
you've read all these reports you've
heard all these things about how he's
perceived to be this guy i I've I've met
him before I've watched his film at us
UCLA I've talked to people that know him
I've heard his interview that what
brings out a real passion in you and
I've heard him say tennis like really
you're a starting quarterback in the NFL
and you're saying tennis I don't care if
you say that oh well I don't need
football wolves because guys are
sleeping in a locker room if you love
football you don't ever [ __ ] say that
when you are a hundred percent of that
invested especially at the quarterback
position you don't say that think about
Johnny Manziel do you think Johnny
Manziel is a sophomore in college it has
a roll ex-presidential on his wrist he's
really concerned if this doesn't work
out do you think if Josh Rosen so this
Rose will grow up in an affluent
household I agree I that's the issue I
do because if you think that this
doesn't work out and if adversity hits
that he can walk away and it's no big
deal to him
affluent house yeah but he was raised
differently you can hear in the way that
he talks in the way that he presents
himself and the way that he handled the
challenge of Eli Manning is Josh Rosen
Wow I think they both grew up silver
spoon in their mouth I don't know but I
am waiting for it I look at this with
Rosen I think that that football guys
have taken this narrative and they've
run with it and that's who he is
I don't think Josh Rosen's a baby
anymore he's been in the NFL for a year
he's just been [ __ ] on for a year and a
half straight through the whole draft
process last year and a year he's been
told how much of a [ __ ] baby he is
personally did he not bring it about
himself no I do not think so what did he
do what's one thing either in Arizona
that deserved it
no I'm not saying Arizona I'm not saying
there wasn't before that what did he do
any of the interviews any of the stuff
that what are you doing playing in the
non slot that's it didn't drive you
crazy no what'd you ever hear Baker
Mayfield or Sam Donald or any of those
guys do the interviews that he did I
don't act that way I just I don't know
cuz I don't think he's done anything
wrong like I obviously I'm not there at
the coaching interviews if he's there
and he's like rolling his eyes and
acting like a douche whatever that's
fine like I haven't seen that I just to
me it's it's a storyline that Steve
wanted to talk about last year during
the draft that's what it sounded like he
was like oh because I just I look at how
he handled it I know people on the
Cardinals team they tell me that he's
been a great teammate they said from the
moment he stepped in the huddle
he had command of the team and so I mean
they kind of have to when you're thrust
into that position
I just think mores being made and I as I
said on the last podcast I did I've
cried rooting for Josh Rose and have a
better career the calimary I'm rooting
for that because I wanted to prove
everybody wrong and I will say this to
go along with that I've called Arizona
Cardinals games I've walked off with the
field on Friday watch practice maybe two
cameras seven media people that's just
sitting there while you're tying your
shoes in the Giants practice or when
you're at any other yeah there's 30
cameras
yeah there's over a hundred meet
and they're all just so what was the
ride with the team when you were asking
about Josh then what do you mean like
about Rosen I was like a teammate now
that as a leader what were they saying I
mean on and off honestly some said that
they bought in some say uh do you
believe that all this criticism can help
him like I do
I hope so because if you're getting this
much [ __ ] thrown at you and you don't
respond you never will for the rest of
your life yeah so that's why you hope
that it makes people open their eyes and
I'm not trying I'm not trying to devalue
your agreement with Steve Smith because
you both share you both share one thing
in common
y'all had a [ __ ] fight damn right so
when you have to fight and you have a
guy that went 7th overall and then goes
I want to go to a better situation you
go no you both are coming from the same
experience but what I'm telling you is
we all know the quarterback position is
different and it's different in two ways
you get the benefit of the doubt yeah
but if it starts to turn you get [ __ ]
amazed I would say part of it when you
lose it's your fault
and I would just go they knew that Steve
Wilkes wasn't the guy halfway through
the year we were in week 9 we were in
week 9 and they were going just by the
way he doesn't control them no you could
sound right away that it didn't work his
number one wide receiver is like a
thousand years old
yeah larry fitzgerald his number two
receiver christian Kirk got broke his
leg in the Green Bay Packer game his
offensive line had nobody and then all
of the nobodies got hurt not you Justin
pew I apologize yeah but I look at that
situation I go we can come up with all
these reasons to defend Josh Allen
having on and off games we're okay with
Sam dart 'old missing five games the
middle of a year and come back and being
more under control we're okay with Lamar
Jackson really not being able to to hit
receivers on the outside but God forbid
Josh Rosen who has zero help around him
I mean his number one receiver was for a
time was Ricky seals Jones now people
are realizing he's not even a starting
tight end anymore so I just I get it I
get it and he did show toughness sitting
in there playing under this passes yeah
I just with nothing
he's gonna [ __ ] worst often sin the
NFL yeah how do you really sit there and
determine not only were they the worst
office let's hear it I went through it
cuz I do all this stuff they had the
worst past I do all this stuff oh the
worst rushing office worse drugs and the
worst rushing defense yeah and they were
the worst scoring yep oh it's just Steve
guy I just wanna see if there's anything
else I'm did you see the video of DK
Metcalf when he went shirt off with Pete
Carroll I loved Pete Carroll another
Croatian by the way he has the same
birthday as me September 15th
why celebrated birthdays with good old
Pete Carroll Pete one looks good for
seven girls
Roxton Nike monarchs he's a baller he
does write the knock you mom he's a
baller and then you know what if Doug
Baldwin is indeed calling it a career
he's another guy in the Steve Smith mold
overworked underappreciated man that guy
did everything once again guy got a
situation
maximized it to the best that he could
earned everything that he absolutely
gotten in the league we are gonna have
later this week you guys really enjoyed
Warren Sharpe and I'm hoping to get him
back during the season to do the betting
thing with me if you saw the series on
Showtime action where he and his guy
crack who you need to watch this they
they're in Gragas and this guy crack is
this bigger guy from New Jersey lives in
Vegas professional gambler he'll go in
there I've seen it on action he's an
election sure I've seen the crack I'm
having them both in studio Wednesday
well I'm coming back and so I want to
talk to them about season-long like
lines and all that but also I want to
know what it's like to walk up to a
Vegas window and just whatever and
whatever you bet 30 grand on they change
the line I've never had that I saw that
when he was doing on the computer in the
what that's what he does that's incent
asked about that but we're gonna talk
more about wind totals the team that is
expected to win the most games is the
Patriots
according to Caesar's they're at 11
under that you have three teams at ten
and a half chiefs Rams Saints Chargers
are at 10 and then everybody else is
nine and a half or lower
so the five teams expected to win the
most games next year Patriots and Chiefs
two teams in the AFC championship Rams
Saints two teams the NFC Championship
and the Chargers of those five who do
you think could fall we talked about the
Chiefs
Saints Saints field I that was the first
team and the Rams feel Rams meets I
think Seattle's gonna shock a lot of
people do ya interest young interjection
full of life people not expecting too
much out of them yeah so I would say out
of those Saints Rams and then what were
the other three Saints Rams Chiefs
Chargers Chargers and Paige do you think
the Chargers could fall out to fall out
so you're going the opposite of me yeah
you think that what Phillip Rivers just
regresses a little bit more I think just
with the competition and division I
think it's not gonna be as easy as it
was last year I I'm looking at the Rams
right now I don't think that they're
gonna have anywhere near this season
that they had think about how many guys
they lost the whole Swaggart thing you
know going into this past season they
thought they were indestructible until
they got into the playoffs and they
realize they can't play the same guys
that they played going in I don't think
that they have near the type of season
so I'm going for them definitely under
my issue with them is I like tail a wrap
the safety they draft it and they didn't
need to replace a safety back there with
LaMarcus Joyner leaving David long and
they get a cornerback it made sense
Bobby Evans and offensive lineman but I
know their offensive line was such [ __ ]
at the end of the year yeah and they're
starting left guard center right guard
right now is Joseph Noteboom Brian Allen
Austin Blythe right now they are in a
weak spot yeah sue is not coming back I
don't think they're that deep on the
deal I and I think that Blythe had a
good season last year but I also think
that part of it was Sullivan playing the
way that he did last and they also lost
Roger South LA yourself and they lost
Sullivan and their most consistent
player on the offensive line for years
so I look at them and go you know what
also when you play Belichick he puts out
the blueprint yep uh-hah to beat you and
we're not gonna see like for a lot of
teams you face Belichick the next three
weeks
everyone runs the same game plan and
then you adjust the Rams are coming in
with an entire offseason of everyone's
studying the Super Bowl exact and I
think that's a huge thing also when they
drafted Darryl Henderson the running
back out of Memphis I didn't understand
that it made me wonder what the [ __ ] is
my girl is yeah I don't understand it
because if you're taking that early of a
pick when you have that many other needs
as you have Todd Gurley there's got to
be an issue and you have Malcolm Brown I
think Malcolm Browns are great back and
I do too but figure this entire time all
girlies and he's fine it's fine it's
fine obviously there's something wrong
yeah with it more than we thought and
like we were talking about I just don't
think that they have the type of season
especially when you look at what the New
England Patriots did defensively think
about all the motions all the shifts all
the figure out the Los Angeles Rams do
on the offensive side of the ball the
minute that that motion happened necking
came off the line of scrimmage
they were peppered by a defensive end a
linebacker a safety that completely
disrupted the entire timing of what they
want to do offensively he did not have
the time for golf to be able to drop
back I thought it was the perfect type
of defense I think it opened up a lot of
people's eyes one other thing happened
that I want to get to before we go a
tradition unlike any other the Jim Irsay
draft call
[Music]
hey Rach how are you man man and I want
to give a shout out to our guy Pat
McAfee who announced the pairing of tank
incredible Celtic so he actually I faced
IDing him earlier in the day and he was
like I'm ready to go he cares like do
you have a whole thing he's like I got
my note he's done stand-up comedy so he
was and the thing with her say I will
say this he has one of the coolest for
me and rock and roll and music yeah it's
got one of the greatest music rock and
roll collections
I mean it's Jerry goes you seen it or
yeah he's got it all up there in
Indianapolis and I went on a visit and
he showed it to me I'm gonna seem like a
Hendrix guitar a Jerry Garcia guitar
here who all this rock David I have this
guitar it's left he's got he's got Tiger
which is Jerry's guitar and that's a
tiger in it it's to happen on that is in
itself a big rock guy yeah number one
rock band of all time
Led Zep over stones stones
you're still a Mick Jagger dancing I've
read too many books about this yeah I'm
sure you get this like pick up there are
splits that's right up your alley yeah
they just didn't give any F Wow no but
that Zeppelin okay anyone else traffic
but that's only would you explain when
would clash all the music in the Giants
locker room we didn't have in the locker
room you had your headphones Coach
Coughlin did not want a surround sound
system because it only brings up
arguments who wants to listen to what I
had seriously I had my playlist all
lined up everything in the last song
before I'd say prayers for my pops
coming out I'd listen to last of
Mohicans that was my thing coming out
have my my dad's initials on my gloves
and I'd roll out man
damn yeah just to roll man yep
feels good good to have you back always
a pleasure brother last thing I guess
just for the Giants fans out there
Giants fans are getting [ __ ] on a lot
right now yeah in the office wherever I
go people are like man can you believe
the Giants they're saying it to me too
what would you tell Giants fans to give
them a little bit of happiness because I
don't want this to be a bad
it's not and it's not anything like we
said it's not Jan daniel Jones his fault
yeah he's gonna have to step up and rise
it occasional what would you tell my
fans to make them happier I mean trust
the process that's the only thing I can
say you're gonna steal our life oh yeah
I'm gonna steal yours notice do you
trust the process and I'm gonna say
listen at the end of the day these pics
and this draft will determine the future
of Dave gentlemen and a Giants
organization so if he's fully invested
in yes and believes in it wholeheartedly
which we all know that he does the work
he's done the homework they didn't want
to lose this they felt that he was their
guy when do you do that you go grab them
regardless of what the media thinks
regardless of what anybody on the
outside things yeah and you analyze it
that way the only thing we can say is
the future will predict itself on
whether that pick was worth it or not I
will say that if I'm a Giants fan and
you can start playing the music we're
gonna wrap this up
the thing that I love is if you were
unsure about get Ulm in' and you were
like I don't want to go through all this
again what he just did was pretty much
give himself an expiration date or a
success date yeah where he made a
decision that if it doesn't go right you
guys move on to the best guy I never met
a quarterback every Giants fan wanted a
quarterback how many people were saying
at a fifth-round gym out of myself in a
2003 draft would start 160 games and
went to Super Bowls and who wrote up my
report Dave did he really yeah so maybe
he knows the things every once in a
while yes he does we'll check it in
three years Dave that's apparently when
you wants to check David deal I'm the
lef koe man we will holler at you guys
later be well guys
[Music]